bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
alors cette semaine dans le kiosque vous
allez découvrir les œuvres du sculpteur
lieue fans exposés dans les jardins du
château de Versailles enfin Nicolas
Gervais nous présentera la nouvelle
saison du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais pour
l'heure place à notre invité
si je vous dis Féfé Kezia Jones Eiffel
ou encore Jennifer vous ne voyez a
priori pas de points communs entre ces
chanteurs et pourtant ils en ont un
notre invité à saisi deux quelques
instants d'émotions bonsoir Julien dumm
bonsoir alors vous êtes auteur
photographe inimantin et vous présenter
donc du 21 juin au 29 à la maison Félix
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux une exposition
de photos de concert alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner un petit peu
l'origine de cette exposition comment
est né l'histoire de cette exposition
mais cette exposition elle a démarré il
y a plus d'un an en fait j'ai déposé un
dossier à la mairie de Montigny pour une
exposition à la Maison Félix c'était en
mars de l'année dernière avec un créneau
qui est tombé synchronisé avec la fête
de la musique donc voilà vu que ça fait
un certain nombre d'années que c'est de
la photo de concert c'était l'occasion
de présenter mes clichés et de revenir
un petit peu sur sur cette démarche
ça marche artistique alors dans la photo
de concert il y a toujours un aspect
technique un petit peu compliqué on doit
beaucoup jouer avec la lumière et c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît énormément
c'est arrivé sur une scène où
il y a beaucoup de choses qui se passent
ça va très vite il y a pas beaucoup de
lumière et ben comment arriver à capter
un petit peu le les sensations qu'on
peut avoir quand on écoute la musique
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à capter un
instant un portrait comme ça la dernière
artiste et ben c'est
traduire une émotion c'est arrivé à
déclencher au bon moment à avoir le bon
instant et puis arriver à à jouer avec
l'environnement pour isoler un artiste
sur scène par exemple montrer une foule
ou un groupe dans son ensemble et puis
et puis choisir
ce qui comment dire les photos sur
lesquelles on va on va avoir
l'impression que ce dégage la sincérité
de l'artiste ce qu'il a voulu donner à
son public pendant son concert pourquoi
des opportunités en fait moi j'adore la
musique et j'ai pas mal pratiqué les
concerts en développement ma démarche
photographique j'ai pu concilier les
deux je faisais tout en abordant une
démarche professionnelle et puis parce
que c'est l'occasion de voir des
artistes qu'on aime bien
d'arriver il y a toujours une seconde
satisfaction quand un artiste va aimer
notre photo va nous faire un tour
positif dessus parce que ça veut dire
qu'on aura vraiment réussi à montrer
saisir un instant de ce que lui donne
sur scène et ça c'est toujours très très
satisfaisant alors
série de photos pour vous alors dans
cette série donc l'exposition qui
s'appelle les émotions musicales c'est
j'ai essayé de de mettre ensemble des
photos qui montrent les émotions que
peut
procurer un artiste qu'est-ce que il y a
toujours un échange dans un concert il y
a un artiste qui donne et puis reçoit
l'énergie du public donc c'est qu'est-ce
que lui il va réussir à donner à son
public essayer de figer ces instants il
y a certains portraits où les artistes
ont les yeux fermés parce que voilà on
sent qu'ils sont un peu isolés il y a je
pense qu'il y a un moment où ils
oublient ce qui se passe autour ils
donnent de la voix et voilà et j'ai fait
une série qui fait partie de
l'exposition qui s'appelle amplifie moi
où j'ai isolé des artistes avec juste
leur micro dans une certaine intimité en
noir et blanc pour essayer voilà de de
se focaliser là-dessus
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
votre parcours de photographe qu'est-ce
qui vous a amené finalement vous tourner
vers la photographie alors mon père
c'est le premier qui m'a mis un appareil
dans les mains quand j'étais adolescent
et puis c'était non c'était un vieux
conte à Flex un vieil appareil
argentique j'ai toujours que j'utilise
beaucoup moins maintenant mais j'ai
toujours eu été passionné par tout ce
qui était un graphique donc j'ai
vraiment réussi à trouver dans la photo
une manière de de développer ça parce
que j'aurais rêvé d'être dessinateur
mais j'avais pas le talent pour et puis
j'ai continué j'ai fait des études
d'optique j'ai démonté des appareils
photos en TP j'ai un ami qui s'occupait
d'un du labo photo du lycée je fais du
développement à l'argentique à l'époque
j'ai un peu laissé tomber j'y suis
revenu avec le réflexe numérique
toujours mon père qui m'a prêté le sien
parce que en 2009 et là je suis vraiment
rentré dans une dans une démarche pour
dire faire de la photo non pas faire
uniquement des photos travailler chaque
photo essayer de les
exactement faire de la photo c'est
s'inscrire souvent dans une démarche de
dire je
fais des photos mais chaque photo que je
vais présenter elle va être travaillé
retoucher éventuellement
post-production il y a toujours un peu
de post-production en fait on fait
maintenant du développement numérique la
même manière qu'on faisait en chambre
noire on va travailler le contraste de
la photo on va travailler son rendu pour
arriver vraiment quelque chose qui soit
la vision de hauteur d'artistes sur
chaque photo donc il y a il y a peu de
choses qui sont laissés au hasard dans
les et pourtant vous arrivez à capter
des
instants il y a pas de mise en scène il
y a
c'est vrai que dans le concert c'est pas
c'est pas comme la photo de studio on va
diriger un modèle on va essayer de
travailler des éclairages etc donc là
c'est vraiment j'essaye de recevoir ce
que les artistes donnent
donc ça va très vite il y a peut-être
une part de une part de chance parfois
sur certains clichés parce que le cliché
parfait qui va être à la fois net
dégager une émotion être parfaitement
cadré etc il y en a certains comme ça où
j'ai fait la photo je savais en la
prenant qu'elle allait être bien et
derrière vont à celles qui passent à
l'écran à la
guitariste ça n'a jamais été retouché
recadrer les sorties comme ça il y a que
moi qui le sait mais c'est forcément une
grande satisfaction
parmi les artistes que vous avez vu ce
qu'on a certains qui vous ont plus
touché où il y a eu quelque chose il y a
des ouais il y a quelques alors je suis
très éclectique en musique il y a même
des jeux parfois photographié des choses
qui sont pas forcément dans ce que
j'écoute habituellement mais parce que
il y a des images intéressantes à en
sortir il y a des belles choses qui se
passent sur scène
là très récemment il y avait il y a une
salle à Ris-Orangis où je suis beaucoup
allé qui s'appelle le plan qui a fermé
avant de réouvrir dans un nouveau dans
un nouveau lieu et le concert de clôture
c'est FFF qui qui jouait avec Marco
Prince et ça a été un concert assez
magique parce que voilà c'était le
dernier concert dans cette salle ils ont
tout donné il y avait une ambiance et
c'est ces instants là où on apprécie à
la fois la musique on apprécie une
visuelle et les photos qu'on en sort
sont
une belle photo qu'on aime bien et ça
normalement c'est la synthèse un peu un
peu magique
j'aimerais bien ouais j'aimerais bien
faire des concours c'est forcément la le
regard des autres le regard des paires
sur sur notre travail la reconnaissance
c'est forcément quelque chose qui est
qui est moteur et qui donne envie
d'avancer donc ouais pourquoi pas alors
nous avons rencontré un autre
photographe qui est sur le territoire et
qui s'appelle Frédéric gras qui est
installé à Élancourt alors il est déjà
élu portraitiste de France 2013 mention
excellence et il vient de remporter un
titre européen qui s'appelle le cap
alors le qualifed européenne
photographeur dans la catégorie portrait
et il nous présente sa démarche est-ce
que signifie pour lui cette récompense
on écoute
il y avait un petit moment que j'avais
cette idée en tête de faire un suivi de
grossesse et cet été j'ai fait un
mariage un août 2013 avec Frédéric et
Nicolas et en fait à la fin de la
cérémonie Frédéric a annoncé devant tous
ses invités qu'elle attendait un
eurovisionnement et moi j'ai regardé son
bidon en fait et je me suis aperçu que
si elle allait être d'accord c'était
elle qui allait pouvoir m'aider à faire
mon projet donc je lui ai je lui avais
parlé durant le mois d'août Nicolas et
Frédéric ont tout de suite accroché sur
l'idée et voilà on est parti elle est
venue une dizaine de fois au studio pour
réaliser la série d'images en fait moi
j'ai tout appris tout seul en fait dans
les différentes formations
professionnelles que des collègues m'ont
donné ou un travail en tout seul etc ou
par les échanges avec mes amis et mes
collègues photographes et le studio il
faut se rappeler que il a juste été
ouvert en 2009
c'est pas vieux et
avoir le couette en 4 ans je me dis que
il y en a pas beaucoup qui ils sont
arrivés quoi
alors Frédéric gras est le seul Français
avoir été récompensé lors de cette
session le 20e depuis sa création donc
depuis la création de ce titre européen
qui n'a que 15 ans alors on le félicite
alors il nous a confié avoir passé plus
de 100 heures de travail pour réaliser
ses 12 clichés
post-production compris vous Julien
l'exposition donc les émotions musicales
ça retrace trois années de concert donc
c'est assez long comment est-ce que vous
avez choisi les photos à exposer
c'est compliqué et qu'est-ce qui était
important pour vous
le souhait c'est fait à partir à partir
du moment où j'ai trouvé le thème le
thème de l'exposition j'avais déjà fait
cette série dont je parlais amplifie moi
j'avais tout un tas de vues différentes
et puis j'ai
j'aime beaucoup ressortir des portraits
en fait d'artistes sur scène et c'est
vrai que je me suis dit voilà cette
notion d'émotion d'échange
elle est importante donc j'ai essayé
d'accès mon travail là dessus
alors on regarde ces photos on les
regarde on les regarde on n'arrive plus
à les voir à la fin parce que c'est
compliqué on est plus très objectif sur
ces sur ce qu'on a fait mais voilà à
force d'itération arriver à dégager une
cinquantaine de clichés qui sont qui
sont présentés un film conducteur au
niveau voilà de
ce qui est dégagé par ses portraits
d'artistes et puis et puis j'ai voulu
prolonger un petit peu ça c'est une
autre série de photos que j'ai fait
uniquement pour l'exposition
qui présente en fait des pour le coup
c'est des portraits posés que j'ai fait
avec des personnes qui que j'ai
photographié alors qu'ils étaient en
train d'écouter de la musique
dans leur dans leur casque c'est un peu
le pendant de des chanteurs qui chantent
c'est là c'est le moment où des fois
voilà il y a juste peut-être ces trois
notes sur un morceau et qui nous font
vibrer et on oublie tout ce qui se passe
autour de notre manière que l'artiste tu
es à fond dans ce qu'il faisait donc
voilà j'ai si cliché là dessus c'est une
série qui aimerait bien peut-être
continuer vous avez d'autres projet
et ben justement avec cette série là
j'aimerais bien
faire un peu plus de portrait parce que
c'est j'allais faire de la scène c'est
facile dans le sens où on a juste à
prendre ce qu'on nous donne diriger un
modèle construire quelque chose voilà
j'ai pratiqué un petit peu le studio
mais pas plus que ça et ça c'est des
choses que j'aimerais développer en
tout cas donc direction la maison Félix
pardon à Montigny-le-Bretonneux du 21 au
29 juin et au site internet également
pour découvrir l'ensemble de votre
travail merci beaucoup Julien merci
l'occasion de sa traditionnelle
exposition d'art contemporain le domaine
du château de Versailles invite cette
année le sculpteur lit fan jusqu'au de
nos ans de novembre pardon les oeuvres
inédites de l'artiste réinventeront ses
lieux
monumentale l'arche métallique du
sculpteur liufane tel un arc-en-ciel
surplombe la grande perspective du
château de Versailles après les arbres
en bronze de l'artiste italien penonnais
pour sa traditionnelle exposition d'art
contemporain le domaine de Versailles
accueille cette année les œuvres du
coréen lieue fan d'y installations
méditatives et minimaliste faite de
pierre naturelle et d'acier jalonnent
les jardins conçus par André Le Nôtre la
pierre représentant la nature et l'acier
comme symbole de la société
industrialisée un parcours qui offre une
autre vision Desjardins une autre
manière de regarder l'espace qui nous
entoure
use
sans parler de son histoire le jardin
est si parfait un peu trop parfait et je
me suis dit qu'est-ce que je peux faire
à ce moment là j'avais l'impression que
André Le Nôtre était en train de me
parler et me disait voilà je t'offre cet
espace si parfait fais-moi quelque chose
de différent et je te regarderai
c'est pour ça que je me suis dit que
c'était un lieu idéal pour montrer ce
que je pense ce n'est pas une idée une
image ni non plus un objet exposé en
fait je dialogue avec l'espace donné et
puis j'essaie de trouver une idée qui
laisse justement la place à l'espace qui
invite les gens à regarder le ciel à
regarder la nature finalement je vous
montre comme l'univers
l'infini dépasse perfectionnement
outre large de Versailles les œuvres de
l'ufane sont disposées de façon à faire
revivre les recoins des jardins peu
fréquentés à l'instar du Bosquet du
dauphin ou encore du Bosquet des étoiles
le sculpteur rend également hommage à
André Le Nôtre avec une tombe installée
dans le bosquet des bains d'Apollon
habituellement fermé au public les
oeuvres de l'IFAN rythmeront le parcours
de visite jusqu'au 2 novembre
cette semaine Nicolas Gervais a
rencontré Jacques porno le directeur du
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
scène nationale et nous présente sa
nouvelle saison
Aurélien Borie Joël Pommera le retour du
Cirque Plume ou encore Philippe
decouflet autant de grands noms qui
seront à l'affiche du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la saison
prochaine une saison que nous présente
son directeur Jacques porno c'est par là
non c'est pas là
heureusement pour nous
j'ai oublié
une cinquantaine de spectacles avec un
bon équilibre je pense entre la danse
les spectacles Eric le théâtre le
spectacle jeune public etc cette
création dans dans la saison dans la
plupart vont être répétés dans le
théâtre lui-même Armida de Haydn qui va
être répété donc créer ici faire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a aussi
géniaux torride qui est un spectacle
c'est une nouveauté puisque bon ça va se
répéter ici avec l'Atelier lyrique c'est
la première fois qu'on collabore avec
l'Atelier Lyrique de l'Opéra de Paris où
les tous les grands chanteurs de demain
on va dire participe à cette atelier
donc c'est quand même une chance
les étoiles sont rondes aussi un
spectacle pour le jeune public et d'une
sorte de cabaret sur un texte de style
mis en scène par Benoît Benoît bradel on
peut citer dans le
monologue Laurent poitrenault avec un
majorité sur une pièce de Ludovic
Lagarde et un texte de Olivier Cadiot
qui est une vraie chorégraphie théâtrale
une gestuelle très précise très très
belle elle est tout de suite entrée dans
le vif du sujet en me disant et votre
python vous l'avez toujours j'en ai eu
le souffle coupé personne ne m'a jamais
fait des avances
gros câlins mais enseigne par jouer
pardon par Jean Quentin Chatelain qui
est un immense acteur c'est sur un texte
de Romain Gary
et c'est une histoire loufoque et
géniale d'un solitaire on va dire qui a
une relation
de tendresse avec son python parce qu'un
python s'enroule autour de vous et vous
serre bien fort l'instinct et les
épaules vers plus la tête contre votre
coup vous n'avez qu'à fermer les yeux
pour vous sentir tendrement
il y a Aurélien Borie avec plan B et
plexus
on a parcours avec Olivia Granville le
chorégraphe qui va présenter le cabaret
discret en cas de Saint-Antoine puis
aussi un projet avec des amateurs qui
s'appelle full qui aura lieu en plein
air alors
c'est comme
ça
Joël Pommerat qui présentera donc la
fabuleuse histoire du commerce
au Théâtre du béné-bat à Guyancourt et
puis Cendrillon
formidable pièce qui sera présentée au
grand théâtre au grand dans la grande
salle du théâtre
ce pays on va devenir légal de ces
personnes pour un soi on peut citer
Sonia qui ouvre la saison donc ce sera
peut-être la quatrième ou 5e apparition
de ces dernières années dans une
création un hommage à Nina Simone qui va
j'attends beaucoup parce que elle va
rendre hommage à la musicienne
incroyable qui était Nina Simone on a
effectivement du couplets qui revient
avec une forme cabaret qui raconte la
création d'une comédie musicale alors il
y a évidemment des grands classiques on
a parlé de la matière apprivoisée avec
Philippe Torreton et Laetitia Deutsch
qui est une révélation du cinéma de ces
dernières années
on a des figures internationales de la
danse bien sûr notamment à l'homme the
king pour la première fois à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alonzo King
c'est un chorégraphe c'est un maître de
ballet absolument
c'est une référence on a aussi les
chorégraphies de forsight William
forsight qui vont être donnés par le
balai des plus prestigieux balais en
France le Ballet de l'Opéra de Lyon
il y aura beaucoup de comédie beaucoup
d'humour beaucoup d'humour dans tous les
registres
la franche rigolade à certains moments
et après la saison de la scène nationale
on retrouve notre Aurelia nationale
allons aux enfants
alors cette semaine dans notre chronique
cinéphile c'est Cyril Adad de
projectionniste à l'espace Philippe
Naret des Clayes-sous-Bois qui nous
livre son coup de cœur
cette semaine notre coup de cœur est le
film de best of réalisé par Giuseppe
Tornatore
est un commissaire priseur de Renaud
véritable institution dans le milieu de
l'art est misogyne assumée il a de
relation intime qu'avec la collection de
tableaux qu'il a constitué secrètement
au cours des années lorsqu'une cliente
lui demande une expertise mais n'accepte
de lui par les côtés les fans Virgil et
piqué d'une curiosité et ne peut se
résoudre à laisser tomber l'affaire
quand il la voit pour la première fois
il tombe violemment sous son charme de
retour au cinéma après une longue
absence le réalisateur de cinéma à
Paradiso renoue avec l'un de ses thèmes
favoris l'amour de l'art la mise en
scène est très raffinée tornatoré offre
à Joey rush l'occasion d'une
interprétation intense et élégante le
film est proposé en version française et
en version originale et est à découvrir
cette semaine à l'espace Philippe Noiret
alors avant de se quitter bien sûr on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine je vous
propose un aperçu des lieux et horaires
près de chez vous où vous pourrez
célébrer la Fête de la Musique retrouvez
tous les détails sur le site du kiosque
toute la programmation je vous dis à
mercredi